welcome back to CBS morning's we have an
update on our CBS News investigation
into a child care crisis in the armed
services that could affect the
military's Readiness now our reporting
revealed some Army Special Forces
soldiers in Florida were driving up to
three hours round trip every day to take
their children to child care now in an
interview that you'll see only on CBS
mornings the secretary of the army says
help is on the way she spoke with senior
investigative correspondent Catherine
Herridge Catherine can't wait to hear
what she has to say good morning to you
good morning Gail for more than a decade
the seven Special Forces Group that's
the Army's Elite Green Berets have
struggled to get access to Affordable
and really child care that's near where
they work but that has changed recently
now that the secretaries of the Air
Force and the Army are directly involved
why is child care so important to the
Army well it's really a Readiness issue
and now Christine warmuth the first
woman to serve as Secretary of the Army
is taking it on as a working mother is
child care personal it's absolutely
personal I mean I I have personally had
that experience of racing to drop my
kids off at the daycare center and get
into work on time or racing to get out
uh to pick them up and sort of being the
last parent to pick them up and getting
the stink eye from the from the workers
three hours in the car every day just to
get to child care yes Chelsea a former
Special Forces soldier who asked us not
to use her last name for security
reasons show me part of the drive that
drove her out of the army it just wasn't
a sustainable solution she and her
husband still in Special Forces juggled
up to three hours of commuting each day
for child care driving from their home
in Crestview Florida past their training
base at Campbell Simons 20 miles away to
where the army offered child care spots
another 20 miles to the south on Eglin
Air Force Base it's unaffordable for
military families to live closer to
Eglin was it impactful to hear from
soldiers like Chelsea who had to quit
the service absolutely I mean you know I
never want to lose a great Soldier and
family because they can't get child care
working closely with the Air Force
earlier this month warmouth announced
plans for a new child care center on the
Army Special Forces base we need to have
our parents have child care that's not
too far away so having it be on Campbell
Simons I think really is the optimal
solution the Army plan goes beyond the
Florida base with greater stipends for
daycare and at least 20 new child care
facilities in the next decade but with
over 11 000 kids in military families
waiting for child care the Pentagon
still faces the same Staffing shortages
as civilian daycares part of what we're
doing is trying to make sure we're
recruiting the best staff we're we're in
a war for talent frankly so we're trying
to raise our pay
and with the war in Ukraine and China
flexing its military power Warmness says
Child Care is Central to the mission we
don't want a situation where
um someone is distracted from you know
the main thing which is doing their job
because they're worried about their kids
or we don't want to lose a good soldier
because they weren't able to make the
child care work good job
CBS News has confirmed that the Army and
the Air Force recently signed a formal
memo of agreement that provides for some
short-term fixes but the plan is to
build a new Child Development Center on
Campbell Simons Tony
yeah you know if the home front's not
working it's hard to do the job uh it
really is a Readiness issue as the
secretary said uh kudos to you and your
team for bringing shedding light on this
issue and then to the Army for hearing
it and and saying yeah we're going to
fix it uh it's gonna change things
Catherine thank you very much you're
welcome